citizens of the reject Nation it is time for
us to celebrate 4th of July reject Style with
secret Invasion Episode thrust today John thank
you for joining us how are you absolutely I am
great he's forcing it Coy how are you you
see the thing about America is we secretly
invade a lot of places so this is pretty fun all
right friends ladies and gentlemen if you didn't
catch the memo the three of us we're going
to be having a real rejects Comic-Con panel
that's right every movie studio abandoned ship
at Comic-Con because they heard we're having a
panel that day so if you're attending Comic-Con
or if you're on the fence you should come attend
our panel and we will of course love to hang
out with you that's the way we roll so ladies
and gentlemen before we go into this leave a
like that would be great also subscribe click
that notification Bell to get notified when our
reaction for episode 4 is up here on the Chanel
and as always full interaction watching long
resync up with your own copy of secret Invasion
available for super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page covers several things exclusive
over there with highlights and watch alongs
included thank you to all who have joined
me in so many pledges don't miss out on
all the fun over there let's get to it
thank you
and AI put this together
[Music]
honey where's my super suit [Laughter]
be careful they always tuck it in the crotch
it's a terrible terrifying terrible tell you
Cheddar Bob that nobody learned why did you join
the resistance Beto I didn't want our people to
keep running not good enough you joined the
same reason I did the awesome headquarters
time to make some poly juice potions
now at the council meeting I told you I
had a plan for taking Earth as our own I
sent three operatives to infiltrate the Royal
Navy the Royal Navy huh the heroes of Earth
will react no they won't I can't
afford them for this episode become
super ourselves oh super they
are doing it we change powers
mirror cologne that's where it all happens
ah the one good de-aging effect it's like his
is so good wanna sit here while you wait VAR
this should put Jacob's men
on their heels Black Widow
this new face of yours is [Laughter] Commander
station and operatives cannot be our unit doesn't
exist Fury that means I don't work for you
yeah let's go that's an intriguing possibility
[Music]
make sure you got enough food and water
because that my friends looks a hell of
a lot like world war three Shooter McGavin even
the broken clocks right twice a day good morning
Fury's Republican two times right I
never harbored any Illusions about the
necessity of you going away but
staying away that leaves a mark
is green still away right now
any plans for the downtime
well you know I never cared much for golf
spycraft I'm thinking I may take up Revenge
let's go
even the books are crazy sorting books by
color is haunting some of the touches are
a little funny production designers understood
the assignment just when I thought I had gotten
past the Heartbreak you came back in the
blip yeah I thought we were going to undo
all the pain together go back to the way we
were but no I love that they touched this
topic I really do really needed to I've been
vanished again only this time it was voluntary
if you're interested in who I became in your
second absence I became me whether the choice
was there when you kept disappearing as if you
were never really here in the first place great
how many men did you sleep with hahaha
they're wearing yellow and blue to note
their division in the colors of
green something important nope
up the phone oh she
intentionally left that [Music]
phone's a scroll someone told
the cops where we were headed
normally we know that Brogan I'd imagine
when they asked him where they could find
you he was forced to make an educated guess
is that what you do I'd lie I'm a good liar
I really like him a lot it was broken
it was weaker than you thought I feel like
a great liar wouldn't say I'm a great liar
you know that's like bad bad skills of
a liar is to let you in on that online
Sight Four negatives make a positive I'm such a
good liar that's why you can trust
me your father called for a party
apparently we mean about you
parent-teacher conference
yeah whoa his hand looks huge unplane will be at
Neptune's coordinates 2 200 hours felt like a leak
don't do it I feel like he said it just to
see if you'd legit choice between having my
story told in ink or Avenue Written in Blood I
choose blood all day long great he's great Brave
you asked Nepali so let's party shall we
come on well you're parrying right now
well you just get an empty cup I like a little
bit of espresso with my sugar are you honestly
puzzled as to why the council would prefer me as
general over the likes of you you want to be very
very careful now you should be grateful that I
haven't sent that back to you in a body bag yet oh
yes don't Ezra Miller him [Music]
even knowing the scene was the scene it was still
that was awesome all these Miss Koreans know it's
murder you don't understand the first thing about
humans we're pretty awful they're in their most
formidable when they're threatened that's right
do you think I'm Gonna Let You continue this war
under the cover of anonymity I'm going to tell
every Army on Earth who it is that's attacking
them you'll lose the element of a surprise too
much info Taylor's too much info we will show them
we who haven't been infected by your sickness
guy stays with me there is it yeah [Music]
now until the end of time my daughter's
name stays out of your mouth oh you got it
oh John Wick over here in this show still
surprises me man that was so painful to
say yeah oh I'm sorry no all right I believe
this is yours what'd you do kindly old guy
has he already been super
scrolled up that hand that
doesn't seem like a thing they can
do yet Power number one regeneration
your dad was unreasonable PTA made him good
horribly you hurt my hand he embarrassed
me in front of all the different me's anyone
that could say what you said to me asked that
I have the bowl to come up in here in a hospital
what do you hear that English breakfast night or
you need inquire optimize well-being no I think
it's a pretty big deal here for that right has he
swallowed his food now no it's enough all of that
with one bite script supervisor having a heart
attack you've got a line on this growl that's
up in the US government it's understood that
you think that implies that I should just sort
of leap up and just to help you like that it's
nice to go inside I'm gonna need you to you know
use your words say what words
help me tell us because I am useless without you
I love you too Nick we can't touch foreheads
here whoever this is you shouldn't have this
number first I want an apology I just gave
hahaha because you rather rudely attached
a nasty bug to my beloved hoot oh she found it
who has a new name now Nicholas Fury pack now
name is Commodore Robert Fairbanks can I get
a photo and a dress should I tell him you're
on your way yeah tell him that you know what
I I don't get the whole dog thing what's to
get dog's a man's best friend it's acceptable
to clean up the other guy's poo cleaning up
your poop for the last 30 something years oh
that's rich that's really what you think that
the whole time we've known each other you've been
cleaning up my mess did you not see far from home
you were just a bench woman nobody
in a dumpy field office in Shield
you know we fed you more dirt and Intel then you
could have uncovered on your own in a lifetime
every time you were promoted inside Shield we did
that every terror attack you prevented how much
do you leverage with dirt no one else in the
world had access to we did that you're smart
and capable guy for you nobody questions that your
life got a hell of a lot more Charmed once I came
into it and you know something I don't even need
to hear a bloody thank you it was my pleasure mate
I stopped four we're here
remember Bob the guy that's got lots of nuclear
attacks I'm sorry I didn't realize that no that's
because you were too busy riding her we did that
wave you got any more abuse you want to hurl my
way I love them so much and then I get to say we
did that and Bob's your uncle you're so this is
the scenes episode this is great oh the show's so
good with dialogue so much heart you in position
worry about your own damn self do me a favor
Fury don't ever change so I just left you [Music]
a lot of noise
that was just actual bullets I think
you just killed some skrulls Saint
your mama's Nick Fury show grandpappy or whatever
that's the kid who's going to launch
world war three I was busy kicking
Bob's ass second floor last door
down the hall can't be there I'm
kind of worried that we didn't see him
say that yeah some doesn't seem right
uh he noticed too nobody calls me Nick Bob
this is not a negotiation Bob [Applause]
to find something to time up your thing
boss thanks for saving my life Fury no
problem Taylor anytime what you're working
on over there Bob oh boy if you're afraid
of going against gravity I could protect you you
couldn't protect yourself coming through that door
fair point we would have stood by you proudly
so stand with me now you're too late enough
for this oh whoa three seconds to give me that
code or I'm gonna aim higher or or maybe lower
oh you got minutes to figure out that code
if we can't make your friend here tell us
tracers like you are the reason people have been
walking in exile for 30 years you sickened me
shut gonna be man
shut up I can't even keep your daughter's
loyalty or is she the spineless
trait of feeding you information
whoa
that is an effect foreign
[Music]
God it must be so hard to find information
in here you got it okay now run
yeah a boat exercise code word Zachary
aboard launch is that the name of the Sun
this was a dumpster fire this whole mission gotta
be hard for you to be fighting with him when deep
down in your bones you believe in what he's
doing I'm not with gravic because I'm with you
the truck is green there
whoa
oh no who could have a sinner
there's a common don't turn around no
you look at me are you a
leader of Scrolls or a worse
or a butcher
uh they just kill Emilia Clark
oh that's Maria Hill and disguises a scroll in
disguises melee Clark another skull sacrifice
themselves for it's a mystery maybe another
scroll was posing as her I think she's just fine
Red Scarf guy
give you some time alone Jason Bourne's passport
your mission you went through all that to get it
done I feel like she could get one professional
in her house St James Church one hour I need to
speak to graphic yeah well you're talking to me
uh-oh confirmed on channels and scroll
yeah it sounded like Don Cheadle
oh damn oh damn so they've like embedded
her with Fury who's not a double agent
except Nick Fury that's gonna be so heartbreaking
man who do we trust who do we trust he's Amelia
Clark dead I think so okay well first impression
thoughts I really enjoyed the episode as per huge
we got some things we got to talk about for
sure um and it was really entertaining it was
faster paced than the other ones which when you're
shooting at midnight is convenient because you're
like oh dang I gotta edit this so shorter episode
all right then on the flip side is just a viewer
I'm like liked it before when it was a bit of a
slower burn and then some of the because there's
some moments here that I thought especially
towards the end when it came to like it was
the plane gonna hit the submarine though those
moments I thought if there if it was more along
the lines of the tone and pacing of the other ones
then I think the suspense of that might have been
more felt and more palpable however uh overall I
still found the episode to be very entertaining
and there's some things to dive into so I'm gonna
kick it off right here with uh not being selfish
and going what was your overall thought oh yes
no yeah I quite enjoyed this episode and I liked
how Reliant it was on yeah like you know just
character scenes back and forth discussions and
things like that uh yeah this is I guess the one
thing is like I was never really that concerned
that like World War III was about to start so I'm
waiting for like the macro Stakes to really like
kick in and start to feel like they're vital
but I really love the character work and the
immediate you know story that they're telling us
through these scenes that were weaving I think
the personal stuff the the sort of on the ground
stuff is really engaging and yeah now I just want
to kind of have the you know big massive Stakes
feel like they're also vital definitely definitely
I agree with all those points question they said
super scroll they did uh somebody's favorite
dialogue in the MCU and I feel like the MCU gets
a lot of crap for just being like oh this is shiny
this is not you know weighted this is all these
things and even though I also didn't assume World
War III would break out episode three of a show
on Disney plus I did feel like it was a show that
allowed weight because of the dialogue this was
a show that has so much personality there's a lot
of really fascinating stuff with Mendelson where
his insecurity and Samuel Jackson's insecurity
are both so beautifully bouncing off each other
because of their 30 year friendship I assume Ben
Mendelson and Sam Jackson in real life have not
known each other 30 years had I not known them
as actors until this show like say there were
two unknowns I'd be like I bet these guys went
to college together that's how good they seem
and that's the writing that's the way they're
shooting it that's the caliber of these actors so
personally for me this is really really impressive
scene work which is what I'm loving out of this
tone and this feels more like a comic to me I love
Comics dialogue you read a comic you don't watch
a comic you're in a comic so this is wonderful
yeah I agree it's like their chemistry together is
like a buddy comedy but deeper than that it's more
nuanced instead of just the surface levels of like
oh we give each other [__] you know it's you
could feel a real history that they're working
through some [__] and yeah they're actually
talking with each other so I think that's great
and uh we definitely want to talk a little bit
more about that but the first thing we gotta
talk about obviously they just Don cheadle's
in the credits yeah so his voice on the phone was
either either roady's a dick or I would love that
scroll he's just secretly been addicted he's just
a jerk what crazy ramifications that is for armor
Wars yes because that was made from a show into
a movie uh I imagine metal tie into Thunderbolts
with a world that hates and fears them coming
for the X-Men there's gonna be a lot of distrust
there's going to be a lot of wait you were this
high up in government you were like number three
to the president and you were infiltrated you
were an alien how do we trust you and then yes
maybe that leads to armor Wars and then obviously
Thunderbolts maybe his retaliation to that then
we found it they're bad guys and yet again the
X-Men like it's all a big Powder Keg and I'm
really loving how they're doing that that's true
I mean it makes me think about the ramifications
of the conversation that took place between Don
Cheadle and Sam Jackson in episode two because
and I will just interchange between calling them
by their sexual names and to their character names
uh because in in that conversation you know he was
saying like I'm shutting you down Fury pretty much
but it wasn't attempting to kill him or anything
like that so if it is roadie could have just been
trying to protect him in some ways you know like
protect him and keep him out of Harm's Way that's
what I am taking it as yeah exactly um or you know
if he is a scroll he might see him as a threat
and being like if there's one person capable of
taking us down it would be Nick Fury so we gotta
stop him you know so it does have you kind of uh
Ponder what some of the objectives and motivations
might be but John yes are you feeling about Don
Cheadle AKA Terence Howard uh it explains some
guys the armor Wars is clearly going to be about
Roadie carpet bombing Slovakia it's true he did
promise yeah I mean that's the thing that people
have been speculating for a while and I think it
would be an interesting entanglement just because
Yao Roadie has worn a couple of faces uh keep my
daughter's name out of your mouth uh yeah I'm I
think that's fun I think it's a fun Prospect and
I bet that's something that they hid in plain
sight in this episode to make you go like okay
the the real shape-shifting game is now a foot I
mean we've seen you know Graphics crew you know
do their Sinister like ooh we're all you know we
are all graphic I am Spartacus but uh you know I
think part of the big thing people are waiting for
part of the fun end games of this Beyond you know
the more sort of mature Marvel is which of our
heroes are you know gonna be Scrolls or when do
they become Scrolls and all that stuff and we've
already had Everett Ross entangled in that debate
and now we have you know the prospect Don Cheadle
so I don't know I think that'll be good I'll give
him a lot of fun to play with too I also think
it's going to be really fun to watch how the
show develops into what are the ramifications on
the film side because a lot of these Disney Plus
shows haven't impacted the films that much but
the next thing is the Marvels which is a sequel
to Captain Marvel as much as this is this is a
sequel to Captain Marvel and end game because
of the dialogue because the conversations but
it's obviously a Captain Marvel sequel so it's
really great to have this in between the martyrs
you know so I'm really curious about that impact
I just hope the screenwriters of the movie were
able to get the scripts ahead of time to watch
it yeah no time no notes that's the that's the
main thing we need to care about scratch you know
um so is Emilia Clarke dead now yes um I think so
I really do I really think her Casting was genius
to have it be like three episodes do you do
you want me to proceed with why I truly believe
she's not dead please you are everyone here
is setting themselves up for a minor spoiler
in case oh is there you know a thing I
know a thing only because I spent a good
amount of time editing your interview with the
director so I got very familiar with the footage
has not aired yet that's so funny spoiler alert
footage spoiler alert the
official trailers [Music]
a good trailer without a spoiler oh that's so
funny I think it's intentionally they're trying to
do a cliffhanger here to make you go oh wow stunt
casting um but no I I definitely am like there's
so much trailer footage that my mind went to I
didn't film 100 million dollars unless unless they
are all deleted scenes at this point we filmed 12
different sequences that we used yeah I definitely
don't think she's dead due to that fact they did
a good job in switching them and they did a good
job setting it up where I'm like in dear to you
but I like that they got this out of the way of
of you know the reveal and graphic finding out uh
you know like I've confirmed you are a lighter and
getting that out of the way so we can get to the
meat because the meat of the show seems to really
be about exploring the relationships and as much
as I like her being a double agent it's going to
allow us to probably have I mean I haven't seen
footage of this necessarily I imagine though
that it would lead to her being able to have
more conversations with Talos which I'd love
to hear yeah and that's more the thing that
I really want to get to can we talk about how
great gravic is graphic is he's like man I feel
like he did such good work here feel like he'll
kill you at any moment yeah it really has that
Vibe and his energy in that museum scene like
we've seen him very subdued I like seeing the
big theatrical like where he's presenting he's
like the blood versus the art and the ink like
all of that was so presentational and that was
beautiful we haven't really seen that side of him
yet and as as the resistance is rising so what's
his performance yes it is being reflected in who
he is John what do you think about Nick Fury his
wife I'll give you 10 points if you remember
her name uh is it oh it's like Priscilla or
something we are one click away from seeing
the cast list is it Priscilla it's a drumroll
yes
those points are coming Fury's wife yeah
please John what are your thoughts I really
liked their scene together early on in the
episode I thought that back and forth than the
uncovering of like the grief surrounding Nick
Fury's avoidance of the trauma of the blip and
all that stuff but yes jumping to the end of the
episode her with the safety deposit box and the
special gun uh I'm well I don't know like you guys
I think she was picking up a mission right
right like she was going there and but but she
already had her phone on her she could have
just a grab her gun yeah you need this gun
uh but yeah I think that that is also kind
of setting up I'm very curious because I
think they're setting up us up for some kind
of emotional conflict I think you have the
Talos and Gaia thing which is a much easier
to understand sort of divide between like why
they're on different sides of the line sure thing
whereas I feel like with Nick and Priscilla you
could have some more harsh and entangled sort of
gordian knot of reasoning as to why she might be
involved with graphic and and the you know what
do you call their group whatever you call them
you know maybe there's some kind of Leverage they
have over her maybe she has been like spying on
him and supplying information on Nick Fury and
maybe you know this will lead us to some kind of
Greater reveal about how the Nick we've seen
walking around isn't actually the real Nick
I'm wondering yeah is the Nick
on the spaceship still Nick
there's been inconsistent limping and
Nick Fury is too good of an actor for
that what I like about the especially what
they do with the Priscilla scene early on
comparing it to the reasoning that Talos gives
to um Nick about why he's siding here because
I'm with you where you get the scene in Priscilla
and clearly she's on the opposing side that Nick
is on and in the big in the beginning part of
this episode she's almost like blaming him for
why she's on the opposing side yeah you know like
she had to become herself and leave him and her
side yeah and fully invest yeah in the scroll you
know cause good character work it's really good
character and Talos is seen in the car they've
said both to lost well Graphics says Talos when
I kept hearing it I was like I guess it's Talos
I haven't seen Talos forever so Taylor is that
the British pronunciation what's going on tylose
so Talos uh I really like in the a retroactive
importance of skrull's element I always love when
shared storytelling can make an impact bigger and
his his entire descriptor of like no no you owe
me the scrolls are like you're Nick Fury was some
of the most genius retroactive importance writing
like that scene by itself made me like this girl's
more than all of Captain Marvel like that was
truly an impactful dialogue and that's that's
what writing can be for me is like I'd rather
see that than a hundred crazy girl War fight
scenes I'd rather see that than like that gave
you so much juice in Marvel and that's the power
of good writing so I want that's why I want this
grounded stuff because that now I want to re-watch
Captain Marvel now I'm really excited to watch
the Marvels and it's all because of a dialogue
scene with a great actor yeah well that's I love
how Talos is like core need is to be appreciated
someone to care about him doing the work listen
I know it's shitty but I've been holding it down
please just look at like a real relationship
I just want to be appreciated yeah and then
Mendelson crushes it without being whiny he's just
like lovely it is so sensitive well that's I think
that's the great thing about this show like this
episode I was really sitting there and relishing
in the combination of yeah quality writing and
performers who can really really like walk around
in it and make it feel 100 like the scenes between
Kingsley benedir and Ben mendelsohn are great and
like Kingsley benedir has this great draw this
sort of like almost lackadaisical quality that
even persists when he does you know kind of arch
into something more showy and more flamboyant
um but yeah just like the little ways in which
they're like kind of like when he kind of gets
up on him and he's like touching him and
he's kind of like choking on him in that
one scene in the in when they're having the
talk and then yeah between Ben Mendelson and
Nick Fury there's just like such great
like open emotional back and forth the
violence too man that hand I was like epic I
guess they could justify it by it heals right
away but damn that is Groot that is Gory
like that it's gross yeah yeah it's and is
there some blood effects too yeah I hate
that it's literally hearing at the flesh
there that's the new thing the disturbing Gore
the upholstery already coming Disney plus it's
already begun here we are wait all right
well one of our keywords is theories so uh
I would uh also like to confirm s episode
confirmed uh I do think the super Scrolls
will be uh more than one episode so I'd imagine
the end of next episode we get our first super
scroll and that's episode five and six yeah
uh my other theory is that someone that is
an Avenger is gonna be revealed as a Skrill in
the fifth episode I think they'll do that yeah
I think I think we're gonna get something huge
like that's gonna be like a big like oh my God
yeah I don't feel like they're interested at all
in doing that I think we'll get a like an internet
Buzzy like bull like where it's like oh my god
did you see I think it's gonna come out yeah
they didn't know they find out by the show
live character was this girl everyone has
been recast fenroll's a scrubber all day
yeah Edward Norton okay Terrence Howard
appears and goes to Maine and they just cut I
just want to hear one main and I guess Maria
Hill truly is dead yeah tart out here for
a scroll yeah there's some answers in the
um no I mean what are your theories uh my
theories is that uh your theories will come true
my theory is that some of the theories are gonna
be wrong but a couple of the theories all right
are gonna be a little bit kind of accurate but not
100 my mind's blown with the way the reaction is
edited that is a breakdown in and of itself of the
episode uh you we clearly talked about the ending
so that's been explained yes um we're re-recaptain
is that the headline now yeah those videos just
try to make sure we have uh all our SEO taken
care of so we're not live when the ending isn't
confusing and someone's like yeah what is yeah
do you mean the movie ended and then we left the
theater my closest friends do them ending explains
they're great dominating Us in views right now
I'm not saying they don't get clicks I'm saying
they don't get Integrity well and uh Easter eggs
from
the restaurant they went to was the Shawarma
restaurant at the beginning did you guys notice
that oh I'm bullshitting no I was like there's
no way I was like replaying all that in my head
wait a second hey there's no I'm lining uh there's
graphic like Irish uh it doesn't matter all righty
guys what did you think about this episode hey
list your nitpicks down below uh thank you that's
the new thing we say Now list your nitpicks down
below um subscribe leave a like keep a lookout
for our Comic-Con panel just go to every single
day and then to go I don't know when they're
gonna be here but I'm going I'm going every
pedal until I find them send this to the page
Crying Ryan Smith I want to take a peek at Kevin
Meek Adrian Tims just wants to live in The Sims
keep it real nagas Heather gear pouring her life
away by Downing beer Ian Simon loves the films of
Doug Lyman Songhai Glover killed his brother
Kayla The King's Speech Alan Ling refused to
throw the ring into Mordor you'll be hurting
after a run-in with Logan Burton Tiara broke
my friend's heart his name was Kevin Herrera Eric
comic-con's 1939. kousy coosey said my skin looks
Lucy Lucy put on my x-ray specs when I look at
Nick X Juan Longoria shut down fangoria get a
whiff of that fragrant Cliff Rodriguez Master T
always has yellow pee looking like a snackster
Lorenzo Baxter differently sane tripped a woman
with a at Kane Lauren American Horse conquering
an obstacle course of course simply faded makes
me feel berated Simeon Justice 94. Rosie Beatty
so goddamn Shady Colin insert a rhyme with Joseph
Stalin or Ballin I feel like we've done Stalin
but either way I'm Falling For You Phillip J Smith
Jr wishes my death would come sooner Jen Smith is
not a Ken she's a Barbie Melanie LeBlanc beat up a
monk good they had a coming all right guys well I
hope you appreciated John's a hyper sarcasm and my
sincerity in this shout out today always thank you
guys for being here you guys rock your all great
human beings ignore John's cruelty uh yeah you
don't have to you know hold me accountable for the
cruel actions I hate everything except you guys
foreign